>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: COLIN KAEPERNICK WANTS
TO PUT PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE
WITNESS STAND.
KAEPERNICK IS A QUARTERBACK WHO
BEGAN THE NFL'S KNEELING PROTEST
DURING THE NATIONAL ANTHEM.
YAHOO SPORTS REPORTED THAT
KAEPERNICK'S ATTORNEYS WANT TO
SUBPOENA TRUMP.
KAEPERNICK FILED A GRIEVANCE
AFTER NO TEAM WOULD FIRE HIM.
DOES HE HAVE A CASE.
WE WILL DEBATE WITH THE REVEREND
JESSE JACKSON.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE TALKED
SINCE 1998.
GLAD TO HAVE YOU ON THE SHOW.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH THIS NFL PROTEST.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE NFL
LAWSUIT THAT KAEPERNICK
APPARENTLY IS GOING TO FILE HIS
GRIEVANCE WOULD BE A PROPER
GROUNDS TO HAVE DONALD TRUMP THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TESTIFY AND WHY?
>> WELL, HE IS EXERCISING HIS
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT TO
PROTEST.
THIS WAS REALLY ABOUT POLICE
BRUTALITY THAT WENT UNANSWERED.
RODNEY KING BEATEN NEARLY TO
DEATH WITHOUT CONQUENCES.
PEOPLE KILLED IN NEW YORK
WITHOUT CONSENSES.
-- CONSEQUENCES.
AND [INAUDIBLE] IN MISSOURI.
THE KNEELING WAS A PEACEFUL
PROTEST.
HE WAS NOT TRYING TO DESECRATE
THE FLAG.
WE WERE ON OUR KNEES APPEALING
FOR THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN 1965.
THERE IS NOTHING THREATENING
ABOUT KNEELING TO THE FLAG.
>> Laura: I GET THAT.
WHAT DOES HA HAVE TO DO WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP TESTIFYING IN A
GRIEVANCE AGAINST THE NFL?
>> HE HAS CONVINCED HIS
CONSTITUENTS AND THE OWNERS TO
PUT A PENALTY BEFORE THE PLAYERS
IF THEY CHOOSE TO DO THAT.
>> Laura: HE HAS AN OPINION.
>> IT'S MORE THAN HIS OPINION
BECAUSE HE IS THE PRESIDENT.
NO, NO, NO.
>> Laura: AS A LEGAL MATTER
THAT'S PREPOSTEROUS.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING TO
TESTIFY IN KAEPERNICK'S SUIT.
HIS LAWYER SHOULD BE SANCTIONED.
>> PART IS THE WAY, FOR EXAMPLE,
PROTESTING USING THE
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES WHO DID NOT
TAKE A KNEE LAST YEAR AS THE
BASIS TO PUSH THE PUBLIC AGAINST
BLACK --
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Laura: I WOULD HAVE HAD THEM
COME TO THE WHITE HOUSE IF IT
WAS 2 PEOPLE OR 1.
I THINK IT WOULD BE FAIR IF YOU
AND ANYONE EXAMINING THIS WOULD
SAY, IF YOU SUBMIT 80 NAMES TO
THE SECRET SERVICE AND THEN 3
DAYS LATER, SAY, OH, SORRY, WE
CAN'T MAKE IT.
AND 2 PEOPLE AND THE MASCOT ARE
COMING.
WE WILL RESCHEDULE IT WHEN YOU
ARE IN SINGAPORE.
THAT'S JUST LAME.
THEY DID THAT ON PURPOSE.
>> WHAT LEBRON JAMES AND STEP
CURRY ARE SAYING THIS ABOUT THE
VIOLATIONS OF THE PEOPLE AGAINST
THIS PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: IS THERE ANY GOOD NEWS
FOR BLACK AMERICA UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION?
DO YOU LIKE THE UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS OR THE SMALL BUSINESSES
CREATED?
>> HE INHERITED A GROWING
ECONOMY.
WITH PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
>> Laura: WAGES WERE NOT GOING
UP.
THEY WERE NOT GOING UP.
>> AND THEY ARE STILL NOT.
EKE
EK
MOST BLACKS MAKE LESS THAN $15
AN HOUR AND A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
MAKE LESS THAN $10.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Laura: WE WILL HAVE MORE
MANUFACTURING JOBS WHERE PEOPLE
WHO DON'T GO TO FANCY COLLEGES
CAN GET A REALLY HIGH PAYING JOB
LIKE THEY USED TO WHEN HE WITH
TARIFFS PUT IN PLACE BY DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENTS AND REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTS.
THE TARIFF THING --
HOW YOU TURN THAT INTO AN
ANTI-BLACK THING?
>> IT'S NOT JUST BLACK.
IF , IN FACT THEY HAD A JOB, IN
CHICAGO YOU HAVE TO GO 3
TRANSPORTATION TRANSFERS TO GET
THE RIGHT TRANSPORTATION AND
STUDENTS HAVE CREDIT CARDS DEBT.
>> Laura: BILLIONS OF JOBS WERE
SENT OVERSEAS AND BLED OFF TO
MEXIO.
THAT WAS GOOD FOR BLACK AMERICA?
I DON'T THINK THAT WAS GOOD FOR
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE AT ALL.
WE LOST BILLIONS OF JOBS.
THIS PRESIDENT IS BRINGING JOBS
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES AND
WORKING WITH JARED KUSHNER.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE NOTHING
GOOD FOR BLACK AMERICA STHAT
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
>> I AM NOT SAYING THAT.
LAURA, YOU ARE CUTTING ME OFF.
IF YOU ARE MAKE LESS THAN $15 AN
HOUR, YOU ARE THE WORKING POOR
AND THEY WANT TO CUT HEALTH
CARE.
>> Laura: HOW DID BARACK OBAMA
CHANGE THAT?
>> WELL, HE DIDN'T CHANGE IT
SIGNIFICANTLY ENOUGH.
THE FACT IS UNEMPLOYMENT 10%
DOWN TO 5%.
>> Laura: NOW IT'S AT A RECORD
LOW.
THE ATLANTIC HEADLINE ON THIS.
HOW BARACK OBAMA FAILED
AMERICANS.
THE COUNTRY'S FIRST BLACK
PRESIDENT NEVER PURSUED POLICIES
TO CLOSE THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP.
>> 26 MILLION AMERICANS --
>>>> Laura: AND RATES ARE GOING
UP.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT YOU CAN
DO WITH THIS PRESIDENT AND WORK
WITH HIM ON PRISON REFORM AND
OTHER ISSUES.
I THINK THESE NFL PLAYERS COULD
WORK WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> WELL, LAURA, WHEN YOU LOCK
PEOPLE UP FOR CRACK COCAINE --
>>>> Laura: THAT'S NOT JUST HIM.
THAT'S BEEN DONE FOR DECADES.
>> THEN YOU FREE THEM UP.
OPIOIDS ARE A HEALTH CRISIS.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Laura: YOU WERE PALS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN HE WAS NOT
PRESIDENT.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> HE CHANGED.
HE IS A GUY WHO LOOKED AT
MARCHES IN VIRGINIA.
HE CHANGED.
I DIDN'T CHANGE.
>> Laura: HE IS A DIFFERENT
PERSON, YOU THINK?
GLAD YOU CAME ON.